[Música]
estoy cantando el dolor del fallo en la
producción del boleto cuando edad de
montreal el dolor del patrón sonó bien
pequeño solo sale en el segundo acto
pero en esta producción nuestro director
michael cal no me ha incluido en la
primera escena que está pasando en el
palacio de educa y es una fiesta grande
entonces este chiquillo está
convirtiendo por todas partes y encanta
todo que está habiendo y quiere ser
parte de la acción es mi primera vez
cantando con la ópera de montreal y yo
soy parte del atelier de break que es un
programa diseñado para ayudar a
cantantes jóvenes desarrollar su talento
y para mí es un gran placer ser parte de
este programa
toda la compañía es como una familia y
te apoyan te cuidan te ayudan con todo y
te desean lo mejor en lo que haces
entonces espero que todos pueden venir
el 15 de septiembre y nos vemos pronto
muchas gracias y chau
[Música]